autre dossier dramatique la guerre au
rwanda le conseil de sécurité tentent de
négocier une trêve entre les forces
gouvernementales et les rebelles
en attendant après le départ des casques
bleus belges et français les combats ou
plus précisément les massacres ont
repris là bas patrice romedenne à kigali
le cessez le feu que les nations unies
tentent d'arracher aux belligérants de
la guerre civile n'est qu'un leurre
c'est à l'arme lourde selon se disputent
le contrôle de l'aéroport
simultanément dans les rues où
patrouillent les derniers soldats belges
les corps qui jonchent le sol témoignent
de la violence qui régit les rapports
entre tutsis et hutus les massacres
continuent témoignage d'un prêtre basée
à 40 km de la capitale
à 6h30 ils ont forcé tous les pores
tentait de départ de l'église de
l'église d'un chrono de notre maison
tous et et s'était retirée ils ont le
fond c'est tout elles ont enlevé des
daims avec bon grenades fusils et tout
ça et après avec machete et nous avons
vu les gens le monde autour de nous tout
vous avez des vanneaux dépenses pressé
et priés de quitter les lieux les 400
casques bleus belges encore présents au
rwanda s'activent car à tout moment la
piste de l'aéroport de kigali risquent
d'être détruites clouant les soldats au
sol
il serait alors pris au piège comme des
rats face au sentiment anti belge qui va
croissant
la formule est signée willy claes
ministre belge des affaires étrangères